how would you address the ongoing war in
Eastern Europe between Russia and
Ukraine on day one of Iran DeSantis
presidency good question well first I
think what we need to do as a veteran is
recognize that our military has become
politicized you talk about gender
ideology you talk about things like
global warming that they're somehow
concerned and that's not the military
that I served in we need to return our
military to focusing on uh commitment
focusing on the core values and the core
Mission wow that would be something that
I could take care of on day one there'll
be a new sheriff in town as
commander-in-chief and I think you'll
see recruiting start to get back to
where it needs to be because people
don't want to join award as if the
military is not big enough